chantal goya est ce que vous vous êtes
déjà dit le prochain qui me parle du jeu
de la vérité je lui mets une grosse
patate
je crois que le prochain je vais le
faire mais comment tu as vécu ce jeu de
la vérité j'ai fait sinon j'ai inventé
reality show comme un oui c'est vrai est
ce que vous êtes déjà dit si je retrouve
cette [ __ ] d'institutrice je lui
défonce la gueule est ce que vous êtes
déjà dit bon j'aime pas les enfants mais
tant pis allan j adore est ce que vous
êtes déjà dit il boit d'accord mais bon
il fait de bonnes chansons quand même il
n'est pas inconnu que jean jacques et
moi parce qu'il aime le bon vin
mais il voit jamais le matin jamais nous
dit et si je dîne avec une soirée doit
pas vous êtes déjà d'y aller après tout
mon mec est en prison vous êtes déjà dit
il est quand même bien gaulée le
capitaine flam kivu non mais vraiment
c'est moi je sais vous êtes déjà dit non
5 dans un seul lycée trop mais ça fait
quand même quelques ya pas de
mathématiques ce service volée j'ai déjà
dit chanteuse sait peut-être pas mon
truc finalement ça laisse fois parce que
c'est parti pour être non mais je sais
moi même parce que j'aimerais bien
chanter un peu mieux vous êtes déjà dit
j'ai envie de mourir là oui je peux
mourir mais ma grande entité qu'est ce
qu'on va faire de moi parce que les
chansons non ce matin seuls à les céder
on est content de m'être que tout le
monde me disait maurice qu'on va la
mettre
et c'est l'horreur vous avez déjà dit
allez hop ma grosse au régime oui oui
quand parce qu'il ya trois ans j'avais
ce que j'ai essayé une robe et la
vendeuse elle m'a dit vous inquiétez pas
quand vous aurez fait votre bébé ça ira
ou ira mieux mais non c'est mon bide
alors que les autres sont rentrés d'art
midi mais décontracté vous êtes déjà dit
et si je me faisais refaire les seins ah
non non pas du tout ils vont très bien
au moins un
sais tu fais pas l'eau c'est à moi ils
m'ont bien vous ai déjà dit [ __ ] mais
qu'est ce que je fous queen à 3 heures
du matin et tous ces connards en train
de chanter nos ballons pas tous ces
connards mais des fois je me dis il est
4 heures du matin j'ai toujours pas
chanter ils sont tous comme des fous
j'ai payé ma ville val d'oise olmert pas
là je commence à m'endormir va voir ça
va être catastrophique
et maintenant j'ai la pêche est leader
ils font pas pas ballon à trente deux
ans à vous ça vous fait pas flipper ça
ou pas du tout c'est moi c'est non ça
veut dire que je suis leur père de leur
enfant c'est ça me fait un beau cadeau
mais tu nous as vu tout à l'heure
rires mars chantal julien l'anac c'est
d'éviter chez jacques marie van et pick
reportage
le cv le best-of élevé
mystère du voyage de marie rose chantal
goya au palais des congrès du 18 au 22
décembre salle bordeaux est le monsieur
meuble à pithiviers j'accueille
maintenant